- There's been a secret under
the streets of Liverpool
for hundreds of years.
(soft electronic music)
A mysterious network of
tunnels, built 200 years ago,
and stretching out for miles, was built
by eccentric and successful
tobacco merchant,
Joseph Williamson.
There's evidence of tunnels built
and then immediately
bricked back up again.
And arches that lead to nowhere.
But the purpose and the
reason behind building these
is unknown, there's theories of course.
One that he and his wife were part of
an apocalyptic cult, and these tunnels
were to be their hideout.
Another that its only aim
was to provide jobs for
the men in the area,
to combat the high levels of unemployment.
A final theory is they
were used for smuggling
or other secret operations
by Williamson himself.
Construction of the tunnels
stopped immediately
after Williamson's death, in May 1840,
and it wasn't rediscovered until 2001.
Since then, a team of local retirees
has made it their mission
to excavate the tunnels,
but with no records to offer explanation,
the purpose of the tunnels,
or even a map of how far they span,
has made it a mysterious and tough job.
(soft electronic music)